[Music]
this movie think like a man is based on
a steve harvey book where he talks about
strategies that he thinks that women
should employ yeah to be more successful
in their relationships one of the themes
is wait 90 days before you sleep with a
guy that you meet yeah is that uh a
theme that's uh explored in in this film
it it is you know because it's based on
when steve was working at ford motor
company he was saying you had to be on
the job for 90 days before your benefit
package would kick in so in theory women
should wait
90 dates you know and make sure the man
is a good worker you know comes on time
you know flushes the toilet whatever
that is right um before you give up the
benefits okay
is this and i don't want to be in
delicate or prying is this a technique
that you've employed in your own life
absolutely not oh yeah yeah
yeah like maybe nine days yeah that's
crazy
that's 90 seems strange to me did you
wait 90 days i'm still a virgin
wasn't my choice
who remembers uh
now we're talking about your life uh
your boyfriend
of course
we'll get to mine later
boyfriend dwyane wade miami heat and uh
there is a there is a uh bit of an age
difference between two of you you're
you're a bit older than he is a few
years yeah is there is there uh ever
i don't know communication gap because
of the age difference yeah i mean we
were going to an 80s party um around
christmas time and and you know he's
super into fashion i'm in this closet
i'm like oh my god you could totally go
as ducky
and it was like
he was just staring at you i had no idea
like who ducky was and and i was like
from pretty in pink yeah john cryer
pretty in pink yeah molly ringwald
nothing and i was like have you seen any
of the john hughes movies right do you
know ferris bueller did you know
anything none of them oh okay and and so
i was like so he's like well let's
google i'm like this is so sad like
these are like distinct memories these
are american classics and he has like i
think he literally believes that like
demi moore just emerged from ashton
um like recently and like there was he's
got other problems if he thinks that
so we when we actually did the uh the
costume he decided to go as ll cool j oh
so he he he went his llc to a costume
party yeah except i think he only knows
ll from like ncis la like not as a
rapper he doesn't know rapper ll not
really no like strange to me
right because he's 12. you know in the
80s he was defeated
yes dwayne wade is 12 years old i didn't
forget that we have a picture of this is
you two and you're going as a generic
brat packer is that right it does look
like he's going as
old ll yeah yeah at least his chest is
and
and i because i was like oh babe i want
to go his banana rama again
crickets and he was like and i was like
google it and he was like what you look
like a hobo i was like that's really
banana never mind right right so it's
just it's impossible to explain your 80s
you had to be there kind of had to be
there he was like i was as a fetus
it's always a nice thing for a guy to
say